foreign
taking my resentfulness out on my kids
for their dad leaving and getting a new
family it's mostly I just get super
frustrated because I'm doing everything
on my own and I just you know let them
along
what in the world's going on this is
John with the Dr John deloney show
show about your mental health
your marriage
here's the goal of the show
the goal to show is to take the nonsense
that's out there in the world on mental
health and marriage tips and how to
raise your kids there's so much garbage
and there's so much nonsense and so my
my goal here is to take all of the
complex science all of the Just
generations of nonsense that's that's
brought us to this moment where
everything around us appears to be on
fire and to cut through all the nonsense
in a simple simple and direct way and my
promise is I'm gonna sit with you and
we're gonna figure out what's going on
what's going on with your mental and
emotional health what's going on with
boundaries in your home and your
relationships going on with your in-laws
what's going on with your spouse your
kids whatever you want to talk about my
promise is I'll sit with you I've been
doing this for years and years and years
and years and years and I mean I have
all the answers often I say I don't know
but my promise is I'm gonna tell you the
truth and we'll sit with you I'm gonna
I'm gonna try to bring some clarity to
this this chaotic space so if you want
to be on the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask a-s-k and don't forget for the best
supplements on the planet thorn.com
you slash deloni that's t-h-o-r in e
slash the letter U slash deloni for the
sale of the century all the time all the
time let's go out to my hometown
the Great and Powerful Houston Texas and
talk to Dear Marie what's up Marie
hey Dr John how are you doing partying
how about you
oh I'm hanging in there I'm not partying
today I lied to you hey so what's
happening what's going on
um so my question is I want to know how
to stop taking my resentfulness out on
my kids for their dad leaving and
getting a new family because I want to
grow a healthy relationship with my kids
and stop being so frustrated how do you
take out your resentfulness against your
husband on your kids
it's mostly I just get
get traded because I'm
and I'm just you know at them a lot
so
what happened with your husband
um take your time take your time you're
all good hon
what happened with your husband
we were together about 15 years
and
I mean we had you know dated for five
before getting married and
had our first
child
um about five years after getting
married
and he was getting older and
obviously I was getting older or closer
to 30 and I had always heard of health
concerns about having children older so
I approached my husband about
possibly having another kid because we
had already talked about having two to
three and that's kind of what we both
wanted
um he
voiced his concerns about you know money
and providing for the kids
and I pretty much just
ignored his concerns
and I ended up getting off of my birth
control
and then getting pregnant with our
daughter
so he uh
he lost trust in me yeah
it's one of those catch-22s where you
have the most precious thing in the
world is your daughter and you wouldn't
take that back for a second at the same
time it's a pretty significant violation
right
oh yeah I'm
super shameful yeah it's both and right
you got this beautiful gift out of it
and that's tough just tough on on that's
tough weight on a relationship so yeah
he says he can't trust you to see does
he bail
um no he's so he stays around and we you
know try and work it out for about a
year
and then um
right before her first birthday and my
son starts kindergarten he decides to
leave and he leaves the house
um and then that's that's 20 20.
um so I'm doing kindergarten by myself
my son ends up getting quarantined and
for his birthday and his sister's
birthday so their dad missed their
birthdays because you couldn't see them
because we were quarantined
um and the quarantine kind of woke him
up
um so he came back and said he actually
wanted a relationship with his kids
which I'm so grateful for so he's in
their life okay but your marriage is
over I I want to be honest with you
there was things long before this
um I won't sugarcoat it and I'm not
gonna kick you while you're down either
this is this is a significant betrayal
and
there was other things going on
Fair
yeah
there's other issues going on
he didn't our needs at all okay yeah
you must have been an honors classes
there in Houston so yes you are correct
I'm sure certain so
here's why I asked you to tell me that
story
just just in the process of telling that
story I want you to go back and listen
to this your whole body posture changed
from you from when you started the call
to when you ended it okay that's a story
that happened to you
and it's heartbreaking and you're going
to grieve that for a long time
okay and did you play a role in that
yeah did he walk out on his family yeah
it's both in and as a as a guy who has
had trouble in his marriage over the
last 20 almost 21 years
um but I didn't walk away on my wife and
my kids do I judge him yeah I do but
also you know like that is assigning a
percentage of weight in the situation
doesn't help anybody he's still gone
right yeah um is he remarried is he got
has he moved on with his life
yeah so he reads like within the last I
would say months got remarried okay
so so now it looks like a new nuclear
family well and so it looks like on
Instagram or whatever Facebook where you
posted stuff that everything's all Rosy
and great and you still got two little
Knuckleheads and you can't sleep and
you're exhausted and you gotta work and
all that stuff right it feels so heavy
um
so I want to decouple
how you interact with your kids from the
grief you're feeling
with it with the loss and death of that
relationship
okay because it's easy for it to get all
all jumbled together
but how you honor your kids and how you
don't yell at your children how you
don't take out your grief on them or
make it their job to make you feel
better
um yeah that's critically important and
you're going to be frustrated by things
over and over and over as you raise
these kids and so learning right now
I am
nothing will ever impact the way I treat
them in fact it's my job to make sure
that those arrows hit me not them
not that they're not that I'm a
pass-through and those arrows hit my
kids through me right so tell me about a
time you just lost it it's got
frustrated and lost it
oh it's it really is just centered
around
either food or like
television like
like if they misbehave or anything like
the repercussion is no TV time
and then let's just up there is that
working
ah no
it's not no all right so here's a simple
thing that I want you to transition in
your home okay
Step One is how old are these kids
oh almost eight and four okay perfect
I want you to take that eight-year-old
and I want you to take that
eight-year-old somewhere special and you
and I both know that special for an
eight-year-old is like McDonald's or uh
somewhere like Waffle House is where I
take my kid but somewhere special a
local Diner or whatever
um there's a lot of rad local places in
Houston
and I want it to feel special for this
eight-year-old is it boy or a girl
a boy okay
um
if you can find somebody to watch your
four-year-old for an hour or two and to
be really special
and when you get to this restaurant I
want you to do the best you can to
position yourself where you can put that
little boy's face in both of your hands
so not only can he absorb the fact that
Mommy's doing something special for us
all for me and for us too
but also
nothing in the world matters the phone
is in your purse everything is away and
it is you locking under that kid and
then he gets to feel it
and then you say Mommy's had her heart
broken
and
me and as you know Daddy moved out and
I'm just so sad and I've I've let my sad
turn into me yelling at you and I want
you to know that I'm so sorry
I want you to start there okay
I want you to do that at a much more
age-appropriate way for your
four-year-old okay yeah
and let that four-year-old know so
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
create a daily practice where you are
putting your hands on the face of your
kids and looking them in the eye and be
almost obnoxiously long maybe five or
ten whole seconds to where it's kind of
weird for everybody
yeah and you'll notice your kid's
shoulders just drop
okay
the second thing is we're going to
switch the language in our house to you
punish them by saying all right no no TV
or you say if you do this then you you
don't get to watch TV we're going to be
done with that language
we're going to switch to
if you guys choose to get all your
chores done
then y'all are choosing to watch 30
minutes of television
and if you choose not to do your chores
then you're choosing not to do
television
strange choice but y'all can choose it
and they are going to test you on it and
you're just gonna have to hold firm and
then they kick and scream and cry and
you can go man I've been through way
worse I my marriage is gone you guys
can't hurt hurt my feelings
and what we're going to teach them very
very quickly is they have a lot of
choice in how good their day is or how
their day is
yeah okay
and it's going to take the pressure off
of you because you hate saying no no no
no no no no where do you all no you hate
that role yeah and that role doesn't
work
and you know you can beat your kids into
submission you can make them do things
because you're bigger than them
I'd much rather them begin to learn and
it's a pain
I'd rather them learn over the long haul
that they play a role in that family and
that they get to choose the the levels
of fun and joy they have in their house
right right and it might start with TV
and they just say well fine then we're
not doing it cool then they're going to
start opting they're going to choose to
not do a bunch of other stuff
yeah they're going to choose to not go
to birthday parties they're going to
choose to not they're making this choice
and I'm not and and I'm not taking any
of that blame but you see how the whole
thing dumps over it's not you against
them it's you cheering them on
see what I'm saying that's what I want
yeah and here's the other here's a big
piece here's number three
never yell at your kids
ever if you have to go for a walk walk
out the front door
when you yell their nervous system gears
up their ability to learn and take in
information is over
okay so it's it's wholly uneffective and
it terrifies Their little bodies
yeah I'm not one of these like
super Atomic woke parents I don't know
what that means but I'm not one of these
like just let the kids do whatever they
want whatever they feel that's all
nonsense
but I want to do things that work and
when I yell at a kid learning has ended
I want to scream at a kid their ability
to process information and actually
learn what I'm trying to teach them so
they can become great adults down the
road over over it ends and so I'm never
gonna yell at my kids
I'm not
I'm going to hold them accountable when
they make choices
I'm not I'm not I'm not gonna yell
yeah you
need to internalize this the greatest
gift you can give your kids is for you
to go see a counselor and get well
because you're not all right
yeah is that fair yeah
you've been seeing somebody
yeah we're actually I don't know if
you've heard of the um like
yeah
yeah so we were going to try something
like that to see if that would help okay
stay plugged in with that counselor but
here's what I want you to say the next
time you go see your counselor I want
you to say I want to learn some tools
so that I can be more present in the
moment when I get frustrated and I don't
just fly off the handle
okay put your counselor on the spot to
not just sit there and talk for hours
about how you feel and how does it make
you feel and how does that make you feel
I need some tools I need some tools
okay
you have much more strength than you
believe you do is that fair
yeah okay last exercise can I give you a
homework assignment
yes yes sir
I want you to go um and you've heard me
do this if you've ever listened to the
show for very long you've heard me do
this a lot I want you to run by Lowe's
or Home Depot or maybe you have one in
your backyard I want you to go buy a
cinder block
and I want you to get some duct tape and
put it across that cinder block and I
want you to write
lying to my husband about birth control
and I want you to carry that around your
backyard for a little while until it
gets so heavy it might be one minute it
might be 20 minutes I don't know
I want you to go to you almost can't
carry it anymore and then I want you to
throw it down in the back corner of your
backyard tear that tape off and never
pick that brick up again
you've got to forgive Marie okay
and then I want you to see that little
four-year-old little girl I want you to
hug her so tight for the gift that she
is
yes both in Fair
yes sir yeah
I'm really really proud of you this is
you saying I'm done with the way it has
been right
yeah yeah absolutely I want you to not
know
anything about your husband's New Life
block him on everything I don't want to
look at any pictures no going down the
same way I tell 18 year old boys don't
look at pornography I'm telling you
don't look at any of these photos
they're not real they're not real okay
yeah
she will understand how bad his farts
smell real quick she'll understand how
annoying he is when fill in the blank
real quick right
yeah yes
and the challenges that he had with
communication with you didn't suddenly
get fixed all of that will be reality
but I don't want you trailing them
around wondering about the life you
could have had
he left he left he left he left he left
that hurts we gotta grieve we gotta sit
in sadness for a while
he moved on he went remarried
and you're still stuck right in the
middle of all this
We're not gonna follow him around we're
gonna chase him around digitally
I'm glad he's still in the life of your
kids so you're gonna have to interact
with him great
but I'm not keeping up with anything
about their life and where they go on
vacation and what kind of new cars they
got I'm not keeping up with any of that
stuff
[Music]
my life with my two little kids and my
mental health and my emotional health
and my physical health I'm gonna rebuild
my life here
thank you so much Murray I'm grateful
for you we'll be right back
[Music]
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hallow.com deloney today to get three
months of hallow for free
hello.com deloney
all right we're back let's go out to
Harrisburg Pennsylvania and talk to
Aaron what's up Aaron
yep how are you doing John awesome man
how are you good good what's up
well I'm not sure how to uh uh move
through move forward with my parents or
work through things or not work through
things
um
there's always been a level of
controlling this with them and things
have just kind of escalated out of
control in the last little over a year
um I mean we've had different issues
throughout I've been married for 11
years we've had different issues that
entire time I mean things have been good
and then every couple years find out
something's not good give me an example
how's it how's it impacting you guys
directly
um for like six months we don't want any
contact what happened what led up to
that
sure um
in relationship to Fister
um some things that
they did with her
um she was getting married and they yeah
just some of the things they did to her
um bro you're being so vague I can't
help you're just like circling Way High
oh man
um I mean it's a huge step for somebody
to say I'm Mom and Dad I'm cutting y'all
off for six months you cannot
communicate with me or my new family
because of something you have done or
continue to do over time that's a huge
step so what's the thing that happened
what do they do to your sister
um so uh there was just yeah some
just stupid stuff
what what I'm gonna start making stuff
up the either either they they set the
bridal party on fire as they were
walking out and they're like like a
horror movie or it was like The Shining
or or they just didn't get the right
flowers like me like
what happened
well there were stuff in regards to the
the finances for the wedding they
couldn't agree on finances you know
started setting things off and then
um she brought up some things from her
her past with a boyfriend that they they
were really liked
um and you know made some accusations as
far as some abuse there and
um they basically told her we don't
believe you
um so that was what really set me off
um and then when we did support her uh
we started getting the cold shoulder we
started getting the nasty comments
and all that kind of stuff
um give me an example of a nasty comment
ah well the uh after they found out we
were supporting her they showed up at
our house and uh you know I was like Hey
like I'm just trying to support her I'm
not picking aside and uh they're like no
well you have to pick a side
what and no I I you know you know the
last time that happened to me fifth
grade
fifth grade when someone's like you
either with us or you're not
um sounds like your parents are very
very immature
is that fair
yeah
and it sounds like it's you and your
sister grow up and develop their adult
y'all's adulthood and your own autonomy
that they are losing of course into
their identity which is we run the show
in these two kids lives
is that fair yes okay so you tell your
parents
they came over to your house like with a
demand letter basically saying it's
either us or your sister and by the way
any family member that ever did that to
me I would do exactly what you did and I
would say you've just opted out of
relationship with me because I don't
interact with adults that act like
four-year-olds Bye Felicia right and so
I would have done the same thing
he as a six months passed
uh no that's been about two months ago
um and yeah they just uh
yeah I mean conversations had gone
nowhere there was yeah just manipulation
working around topics so I took them up
a letter and said hey like we need we
need this and this way we can't
have this conversation get turned around
um so they sent me a letter about three
weeks ago and said hey like we really
want to fix things
I don't know what to do do I go back you
know and try and have another
conversation or is that just making
continuing the cycle
um
I have a core Rule and it's this I only
speak if I can be heard
and so if I see a loved one A friend of
mine just doing something so dumb with
their money
all right they're just acting like
idiots
or a buddy I don't have any friends like
this but let's pretend I did like I had
a buddy that was like man I've really
met this girl and we're kind of like
we're not hooking up or like we go have
drinks once a week or something like
that and he's married to a friend of
mine
um
I
if they say hey man what do you think
about that
or am I crazy bro you just opened the
door like a vampire and invited me in
I'm coming in I'm Gonna Give You full
picture but if you're being done with
your money and you don't ask my I'm not
just gonna start I'm just not gonna
start
giving you wisdom or advice or what I
think is the right thing to do I used to
do that all the time and I almost became
abusive with that
and so that's why I eat on this show I
wait till people call me and then they
call me and then I'm like all right I'll
tell you what I actually think about it
and so if you think you could sit down
with your mom and dad
and you talk and they would listen
and you were able to say
my sister your daughter came to you and
said I got I was abused either
emotionally or physically or sexually
and y'all sided with her old
ex-boyfriend
and when she reached out for somebody
and I as her brother stepped up
you made me pick sides
I don't do that
and so if you ever
um want to re-engage with us you have to
choose to never again put me in a
position where I'm gonna have to choose
sides between my mom and dad and my
sister not gonna do that
and if you think they could hear that
conversation and I'm sure there's a host
of other things that y'all need to talk
through right
um because how did you say it um
they said some things and actually they
got in their car and drove over to your
house and said you have to cut your
sister out and shun her to Dwight
Schrute style or right like that's
that's more than just saying some things
right so I I know that this has been
bigger issues if you think they could
hear it I don't have a problem with
having uh another conversation but that
conversation needs to be something that
you've written down and that you read to
them and they commit to listening and
not responding before you get finished
okay if you think in your heart they're
not going to listen to anything they
never have for 30 years they've never
listened they're not gonna listen now
then
you don't even have to respond to the
letter because you've given them a
boundary and that's in six months we'll
reconvene
so cool in six months um I'll write them
back and say I got you a letter thank
you for sending it period
that's it sometimes when somebody puts a
big strong boundary it can be
manipulative to throw a
um
woe is me please forgive me or they
didn't even ask for forgiveness but a
woe is me I want to fix this grenade
over the wall of your boundary hoping
you'll pick it up
and at least send a text because if you
send a text now we got a little crack in
right
what does your gut tell you
I tells me they're that nothing's
changed
um go with your gut go with your gut
okay yeah I mean my thoughts were like I
gave you enough stuff to apologize for
like if there was a you know if there
was a tink in your armor if there was
you know a softening of your heart
whatever like you know you just said
something you said you know apologize
for something apologize for whatever
and I didn't see any of that yeah
um if somebody sends you a note that
says we need to fix this I really want
to fix this and it doesn't include an
apology
then they're going to want you to
tell them you're sorry and fix all the
stuff
but at the end of the day
they opted out of relationship with you
by forcing you to choose between you and
your sister which is just insane and
um
you called their Bluff and you put up a
boundary good for you I'm really proud
of you man I'm really proud of you
um but if your gut says man they're not
going to listen they're not going to
hear a word I say then I say save your
breath save your breath are you gonna
feel guilty yes are you going to be sad
that your parents act like they're so
mature like that yes are you going to be
heartbroken that your parents won't uh
forgive you I mean won't ask for
forgiveness yes don't apologize yes
it doesn't mean it's not the right thing
to do it's hard but doesn't mean it's
not the right thing to do I'm proud of
you man proud of you for protecting your
family I'm proud of you for sticking by
your sister even it was hard and you
defaulting to belief over accusation
more women need men in their lives that
default to belief and
um
man I'm proud of you for not just
getting sucked right back into the
Vortex when your parents wrote you some
mushy letter without an apology in it
good for you man good for you hard hard
adult stuff
I wish it was different but we gotta
choose reality right and I'm proud of
you proud of you we'll be right back
all right let's go back to Texas a lot
of Dallas Texas and talk to Alexis
what's up Alexis
hey how are you Dr John I'm good Kelly
just gave me an ugly look
I I spent half of my life in Houston in
the other half in West Texas and in both
places we were trained like militantly
to not like the DFW area but that's
where Kelly
that's where her heart lives right
inside of Jerry world stadium and so
alas understandable I'm glad to be
talking to a Texan how about that what's
up Alexis
so I have been with my boyfriend for
over two years now when we're starting
to have the getting engaged and getting
married talk ew I know are you excited
I am excited that's awesome but it leads
to uh the question
what are some ways to have the combining
money talk and have it progress for lack
of better words positively when he tends
to double down on his opinion
and I'll shut down or get really quiet
I think the answer to your question is
in your response to
your boyfriend's disregard for your
value system
almost a hundred percent of the time not
quite but almost 100 of the time in this
situation he also there's other things
that he just blows you off on
other things that you think are
important or dreams you might have or
values you might have that he just blows
you off
money is just one of them and it's a big
one
yeah
um
most of the time people come at this
conversation very tactically
when we get married I really want to
have a combined checking account I want
to have
um do all of our investment stuff
together and then the other partners
like no way dude I want separate
checking accounts you pay these bills
I'll pay these bills we'll both pitch in
for the mortgage which by the way is a
recipe for financial and relational
disaster it's a terrible idea
um but
the better way to start that
conversation is here are a few things
that scare me to death about marrying
you
one is I'm so scared I feel so unsafe if
you have one checking account and I've
got another
I don't feel whole that way
I also don't feel safe it when you go
out all weekend and you don't even call
home I'm just making stuff up now
um
a way that I will feel safe as your wife
is if we both have a single account and
both of our paychecks go into the
account and we make a budget together
and we dream together and we create a
future together and it's not we're not
co-managers of our household
but we are in this thing ride or die
yeah and maybe asking him what scares
you
so much about sharing an account
because if he's going to get married to
you legally
if he's gonna create a human with you
sexually and biologically
the idea that I still need to hold on to
this one thing it just feels like
Madness to me
yeah see what I'm saying and so but it's
fair to ask him what scares you so much
what what is it in your soul and maybe
as a kid his
um I call it Financial infidelity maybe
his dad stole a bunch of money and spent
it like a maniac and mom was just taking
her tiny little paycheck and trying to
pay bills and keep the house afloat
maybe that happened or maybe mom was
just a reckless spender and dad was
always trying to figure out how to make
things work who knows what was going on
um but giving him an opportunity to talk
about how this thing makes you all feel
why that's such a scary thing
um but at the end of the day I would say
this
if you don't trust me enough to share
bank accounts our relationship is not as
strong as I thought it was
and I know that's a scary caustic
statement
but I'm telling you if you were a close
friend of mine you were my sister or
something like that and you're
considering marrying somebody and this
was a deal breaker for them I would look
at you and say that's a deal breaker for
me yes
how strongly do you feel about him
very strongly
I want you to practice not shutting down
when somebody leans up against your
value system
yeah
why do you have that value why do you
want to share accounts
did everything they share accounts
because it's kind of just everybody
around me has always shared accounts and
I know his parents don't share accounts
let's throw parents out the window why
do you want to
just to feel like we're both
contributing to something okay so like
it's not just his piece of furniture my
piece of furniture There You Go our
furniture and the beauty of getting
married is two people decide to dissolve
their autonomy and create something
completely new that has never existed
before and that's this marriage
and that doesn't mean when you dissolve
your autonomy that means you are living
for somebody else doesn't mean you
dissolve your identity
you're still you you still have your
cool weird things that you're into and
you still have your creativity and the
things that you like you don't dissolve
your personality but you do dissolve
your autonomy I'm living for them now
and they are living for me
and we do this thing together we're
building something new
and if you're both paying rent into this
new thing then you have a Business
Partnership you don't have a marriage
yeah business Partnerships are often an
absolute train wreck right what's it
what's his what's his sentiment why does
he say that
I think
and she's married before and divorced so
I don't know if that necessarily has
anything to do with it no Alexis that
has nothing to do of course that has
something to do with it yeah so I think
his fear is Justified
I get it yeah totally get it I do
understand like I understand like
him not wanting to
but if he's gonna get remarried
he can't get remarried with one foot not
in the boat
yeah because he put both feet in the
boat last time and the bow got tumped
over
yeah and so if he's not ready to put
both feet in the boat he's not ready to
get married
yeah you can't you can't get remarried
halfway you got to go all the way in
which means he's got to go into another
relationship with the idea that he's
going to be vulnerable again and he
could get hurt really bad again that's
what he's choosing to do
yeah and if he doesn't do that he's not
ready to get married he just wants to
play house with you
yes and I know that sucks for you
I know I know
let me tell you this there's no path
forward where you shut down and just let
and let yourself get run over
okay
you might get what you want which is a
quote-unquote husband but you're gonna
get a mess
relationally right
yes
but I think if y'all sit down and say
let's dream together what do we want
this thing to look like what do we want
this whole thing to feel like and how do
we get there how do we reverse engineer
that
I think you land on
I I won't feel safe in this marriage if
we're not both
joined in our values we're not both
joined in commitment to this thing and
we're both not joined with our financial
accounts
I just don't feel safe
and I recognize you don't feel safe
because you got burned before
we gonna do
it's a hard scary place to be Alexis
I do appreciate you having the strength
and courage to say this is a big deal to
me big deal
I want you to practice as you start to
feel yourself shut down in the future I
want you to practice saying uh I'm
shutting down I'm shutting down not this
time not this time this time I'm gonna
stand here as uncomfortable as it is
come what may my two feet are planted in
the soil in Dallas Texas I'm gonna stand
up this time
the more you practice it the stronger
you will get
and then you can be equal Partners in
this relationship as y'all build
something completely new it's awesome
we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we're back and we have a
generational divide maybe a geographical
divide going on definitely geographical
not generational all right so some point
in this show I said the words
tumped over said it tumped over
I thought you were having a stroke y'all
don't know what tumped over means I do
no because it's not a real word
how's it not a real word I used it if
only three states in the entire country
use it okay
it's about I've learned because we did a
survey on this a few years ago when a
friend of mine said it and half the room
went what that it's about a five-state
radius that know what tumped over
otherwise they don't it's like Texas
Mississippi Alabama it's a small area
all right that's not great company I
know but we're by far the superior one
in that one that is true but as soon as
you said it you could as soon as you
said it I was like lots of Texas saying
because all of them in here were like
what okay so let's let's clarify
if something gets dumped over stuff
falls out so if you dump over a bucket
all the stuff in there dumps out falls
out
if something tumps over it just fell
over like he got drunk and jumped over
yeah yeah like okay and when he tubbed
over all of us everything that was in
his cup dumped out dumped out he could
be in a boat and he's drunk and he
fought and he thumps out of the boat the
boat tumps over why would you not just
say fell over because it's better
that way just fell over what kind of
are you we used elevated language
on this show how long have you been on
the show for like two years you realize
how how I
how how sacred I hold my vocabulary
you're not a bit of a Superfluous word
choice if you ask me but that's fine
see that's how dumb these guys are it's
Superfluous genius good grief Gosh guys
just making up words they don't
understand that we're here to educate
them that's right on our sayings
Superfluous it's Superfluous my gosh I
bet you say thermometer too instead of
thermometer don't you
guilty golly America this is our
schooling system fix it fix it all right
hey that's the show for today y'all stay
in school don't do drugs stay in school
for God's sakes because
vocabulary quizzes bring them back
or maybe just put it in chat gbt that'll
help everybody put that in chat GPT and
see if it knows what tumped over is I'm
confident
and if it doesn't
we're doomed ladies and gentlemen see
you soon
[Music]